i'm joined by three of my favorite
ladies who just so happen to be the
stars
of free forms the bold type katie
stevens
megan fahey and aisha d hi ladies cheers
hello
i'm loving the variety of everything
that green juice looks great thanks yeah
i'm trying to
i start off the day with green juice
salad smoothie
you know lots of healthy stuff vitamins
and at the end of the day it's
pizza i have not green juice
is it water or is it straight tequila
let's talk about season four is coming
back on freeform on june 11th
ready these are our new friends wow
hello when we last left off with kat i
couldn't believe it but she was actually
fired from scarlet shocking
the board has voted to terminate your
employment
okay what can you tease about what is
coming up for her
in the second part of season four i will
say that this is probably the first time
that we see cat
face her privilege in a more kind of
like immediate
and real way so it's the first time that
she doesn't have the security blanket of
scarlet
and you know the security of of that
kind of
financial stability so we're gonna get
to see her um
you know stumble a little bit but i
think it's just as inspiring as seeing
someone kind of
on a trajectory towards success because
success isn't really linear it doesn't
just you know go up and down
sometimes make a misstep you know
and this megan miss sutton brady
is now officially a married lady that
was
so much fun to see in this season four
teaser we're getting a little hint of
maybe baby
i'm just nauseous and exhausted
my gonna hurt wait are you serious
what was your reaction when you found
out that that could be
the new storyline for sutton in season
four
i mean i love it i want fake belly give
me the whole thing no um
i think it's cool i think that starting
a family with someone is
you know a conversation that involves a
lot of
uh different elements and i think that
it's a topic that our show hasn't
necessarily covered yet it's a really
really interesting
conversation to have especially for
sutton as a young woman who is
just finally becoming the stylist that
she's been dreaming to be her entire
life
so now that that's fallen into place
with her and she's with the person she
wants to spend the rest of her life with
i think it'll be really cool to watch
the two of them sort of navigate what
that means
together i really like to have some
children on the set though
i know that they say never to work with
children or animals but
i don't care i want a cute baby to be a
corner
on me and it's a very selfish one but
you know that's my truth she's having a
moment let me have my moment
katie when we last saw jane she made
such a challenging decision both in her
personal life
and in her health if i stay with you
it would be for the wrong reasons
it would be because i'm scared
scared to be alone scared to go
through the surgery alone
that's not a reason to stay what's her
mental state when we pick up with her in
season four i mean she's kind of in
rough shape
i spoke a lot with the writers about you
know i had gotten the storyline and i
knew that it was
heavily dealing with the post-mastectomy
journey of it all
involving her physical healing but i was
like i feel like she has a lot of
emotional healing to do
too because she just broke up with a
person that she thought was supposed to
be her person
and i don't think that that's something
that you just like breeze over
so i was really happy that the writers
found
a way to kind of put those two things
together
um and and something that i'm really
happy that we're doing
is is kind of touching on her body
insecurities now
i don't know i mean they just don't seem
like me
i miss my old ones i feel like as women
you know just as a whole without having
surgery or anything i think that we're
often
so dissatisfied with ourselves and our
bodies and
how we feel about ourselves and how we
feel we look
and i always talk about how we never
talk about that on the show like the
girls are never
complaining about how they feel about
themselves which i feel like
is what women do with each other so
often
so then on a heavier heavier spectrum to
be able to kind of tell the story of
jane kind of being like
i did this thing for my health and i
thought that i was gonna
just get it done and feel fine and be
okay
and i don't feel at home in my body and
i don't feel like these
feel like me or look like me and you
know having that as a layered
insecurity for her i think is a really
powerful story to tell
on top of the physical healing and and
all of that
and it's interesting because the bold
type i feel like was one of the first
shows
that was impacted by covid19 you guys
were filming i believe your last
two episodes of season four what was
that like for you guys and
and what's the game plan are we just
getting a shortened season four
we had to start early you know obviously
to keep everyone safe and healthy and
luckily we managed to finish six before
we had to do that
so we still have six to air but i think
we're all kind of
really missing each other and and really
missing our crew too because they're a
big part of like
you know the experience of being there
and we didn't really get a proper
goodbye so hopefully
we're hoping that uh we get a season
five and then um
get to kind of finish off those episodes
as part of
season five because the stories that we
were telling in 17 and 18 were really
great and i know we were all really
excited
about them our editors and our writers
did the best
that they could to make 16 feel like a
finale so hopefully people can
watch it keeping in mind that it wasn't
the intended finale but we're thankful
that we're one of the shows that got to
actually have enough episodes that were
filmed to give
people new content because i know that's
not the case for a lot of other shows
you